you left la you said four years yeah
what did you do to recharge I mean just
I'm sure being out of La is enough to
just make someone just feel like human
being again yeah looked her a long time
to understand that I I lived you know I
ran away from home when I was 15 and and
came to Los Angeles and I was here for
20 years and I just needed a break and I
needed a break because I you have to
have such tough skin to live in LA and I
just didn't have tough skin at the time
and I wanted to go someplace where I
felt like there was such a huge artistic
community where it was just about making
art and so I went to New Orleans and
just spent a lot of time there listening
to live music going to see live art
shows working with other filmmakers
helping other filmmakers like kind of
contributing my time and the things I've
learned and it just it was rejuvenating
for my soul and for my art my art it's
interesting too that it is a tough place
I do have to have tough skin but so many
artists don't I mean that's what makes
them artists as they feel and they've
been through a lot of pain
she is that sound and so that brings
them to this other place in their mind
to create so how does someone have
just I think that sometimes um I think
most artists are very vulnerable but I
think there comes a point in your career
where you kind of become a product and
when you become a product I think you
have to have a tough business skin
because you have I mean in order to
thrive you have to connect with people
and you have to connect with an audience
and you have to sort of sell your
tickets and and make your movie
lucrative so you gotta have tough skin
to do that business side of it and I'm a
producer so I'm not only just a director
which is more artistic but a producer
you know I'm have to be very business
minded and I don't want to say savvy
because I don't like that word but
really you know have some thick skin to
deal with the kind of people you have to
deal with to make deals
you